I was cute what do you guys just plan
with your dolls here little fight scene
going on is it a little choreograph kind
of setup is this guy
Berlin techno rave is just rolled in
from 3 a.m. tickety tickety tickety
interesting there's no one for toy in
here that on purpose or the ruse yeah
sure I heard that before the civil civil
war no for what little doing stand
around kind of pointin at each other
look at me I'm an idiot see what would
really happen if there was a fight
between all of us basically you go a
little bit like this oh look at me am i
man and I'm just got a hit over there
and look at me I'm Captain America and I
got smashed over there like a little fly
it's just a kid big and fall over
he's not even real guns guns aren't cool
so you can hop the table bunch of losers
these guys a lot of those guys they can
stay and you can come with me because
we're now mates so thanks for nothing
everybody welcome forward as a set of
Infinity Ward if you didn't know what's
going on obviously Chris Hemsworth is
just having some fun he's on the set of
Avengers infinity war they're probably
getting ready to film his scenes and
this is just a funny way for them to say
hey you know this is going on we can't
show you any actual footage so we're
going to promo it this way so for
everybody that's complaining about
spider-man dropping way too much of the
plot in their teasers they could
actually probably learn a lesson from
this just have Robert Downey jr. play
with his action figures for a couple
minutes but there's a couple things
going on in the background that you may
not have noticed the first time you saw
this but I'll say there is a new round
of the spider-man giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber or
leave a comment on this video funny
enough is actually for the action
figures but if you look behind Thor
there it looks like a partial of a
Quinjet I know everybody's wondering how
they get into space obviously that's
where Tony Stark comes in star-lord is
obviously a big part of infinity war
Thor knocks them over while he's playing
with them pretty much everybody from
guardians is confirmed but that
looks nothing like the aqua line stuff
that you see in the guardians movies so
that's definitely not the Milano so I'm
just guessing that it's a souped up
version of a Quinjet the Tony Stark is
just modified so that they can actually
get into outer space when they need to
but the other thing about this is
obviously it just confirms some of the
roster so pretty much ever
buddy knew who is going to be an
infinity war but this is just a way for
them to show you yeah Black Panthers in
here
yes spider-man's in here I love the way
he totally shades him too he's just a
little kid he's not even real boom you
go down pretty sick Hawkeye burns I feel
like every Avengers movie is just
another opportunity for them to rip on
Hawkeye for being a guy that Shops at a
sporting goods store for all his gear
but most of these other action figures
are just the standard ones that you'd
find on the Shelf so that doesn't
necessarily mean this is what their
costumes are going to look like during
infinity ward's these are just here for
fun
so like there's the Hulkbuster in the
background here there's two Ironman
action figures so while it would
probably be appropriate to bring the
Hulkbuster armor if you're going to
fight Thanos it probably wouldn't be
that much more effective than a normal
Iron Man suit he would crumple them both
like soda cans so really just besides
them having a little bit of fun the
other big thing here is the fact that he
has his hammer in it and they even took
the time to add the hammer sound effects
in post-production so if you ever
wondered if they're posting something
from their cellphone maybe it's an
Instagram video just for fun or if it's
something that's highly choreographed
and there's like some big social media
push behind it then taking the time to
add movie accurate sound effects is just
a hat tip to that so it doesn't
necessarily mean that Mjolnir is going
to appear in infinity world like this
there was a picture recently with the
Russo standing with the hammer on the
sets as they've been filming on for the
last couple weeks it seems a lot like
the place where Thor is when he has his
visions during Avengers age of Ultron
when he's in that Asgardian Hall and it
seems like everybody's dead and they're
in the afterlife and he just starts
talking to Heimdall a lot of that looks
like the same type of architecture so it
could be the realm of death it could be
fan OSes sanctuary it could be the place
that he builds for death when he's
assembling the Infinity Gauntlet so let
me know in the comments what's that you
think this is doubling for but people
just saw the hammer in this and there
was a caption that read worthy so people
are like wait a minute does that mean
that yo near is going to get reforged
the exact same way because in that
infinity war preview that they released
it seems like Thor is wielding either
yarby or the big axe that he has in the
comics were ultimate Mjolnir which is
just the hammer axe is just a more
hardcore version of his normal hammer
from another universe and for those of
you asking about spider-man homecoming
post-credit scenes I'm not
affecting anything for thor ragnarok or
any of the work cosmic stuff that's
happening spider-man homecoming is made
to be this real world earth based movie
so if anything I think the post-credits
scenes will be Iron Man specific maybe
some Captain America maybe some black
panther just because that's the next
earth-based movie that's coming up even
though it's taking place on the other
side of the earth but there's like a
99.9% chance that they will attach a new
theatrical Thor trailer to the movie so
it'll play separately it'll have a whole
bunch of new footage let me know though
what do you want them to attach to
spider-man homecoming I feel like it'd
be really awesome to have a Captain
America moment just because they put him
in the movie in such a funny way so
would be a funny callback to that
physical fitness video and there really
aren't any movies with Captain America
before infinity war that we know about
like we think he might be somewhere in
black panther maybe as a post-credits
scene but he doesn't have any big
features coming and if spider-man is
going to be on the outs with Iron Man
just a little bit it'd be fun for him to
lean more in the direction of his friend
from Brooklyn the People's Champ
and I feel like that's what he and
spider-man have in common is it a Spider
Man is a man of the people he's kind of
a street-level hero even though he's an
intern to be an a-list Avenger so they
both come from very meager beginnings
unlike Tony Stark so even though Stark
is still very aspirational I feel like
Captain America is a better role model
for someone like Peter Parker but he's
not really the science geek that Tony is
so I feel like that's why spider-man
likes him so much Iron Man is really
cool but they also bond his team science
bros especially since Hulk isn't around
so he's like the surrogate science bro
so let me know in the comments where do
you want to see Captain America pop up
before infinity war believe all your
requests for more Marvel videos there
was a ton of spider-man that dropped but
people didn't seem super excited about
new spider-man footage so I'll try to
figure something out there's still a lot
of really cool stuff happening with
spider-man homecoming but it feels like
a lot of people are sleeping on the
movie right now so while you wait for
everything you can click here for that
big two-part spider-man homecoming
special on the Disney Channel and you
can click here for brand-new flashings
and for
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five see you guys tonight
you